[Musik]
MURAT: Dam-da-dam-daaa! Dam-da-dam-daaa!
Oh, die Wurst! Sally!
Wasser! Sally!
SALLY: Murat!
MURAT: Feuer! Sally!
Murats 5 Minuten!
SALLY: Murat, ernschthaft?!
Heute machen Güni und ich… Pass auf.
Nein, er muss weg!
Herzlich willkommen zu Murats 5 Minuten.
Heute machen wir richtig coole Crispy Chicken mit Kartoffelspalten.
Wir nehmen wir dazu wirklich Chips - meine Lieblingschips übrigens.
Das ist keine Produktplatzierung.
Mir wird eine Person dabei helfen. Ihr kennt die Person.
Der Bundesverfassungsschutz kennt die Person auch.
Das Bundeskriminalamt kennt diese Person auch,
und zwar ist Güni heute bei mir.
Murats 5 Minuten dauern manchmal auch länger.
[Jubel] Wir wissen eigentlich nie, wie lange das dauert.
Das machen wir.
Bist du eigentlich glücklich, wieder mit mir zusammen?
Wir 2 wieder?
GÜNI: [Doing] Ich freue mich auf diese Sache.
MURAT: Ja, okay. Weil du musst dann immer ehrlich sein, gell?
GÜNI: Ja, du willst eine ehrliche Antwort.
MURAT: Was wäre die ehrliche Antwort?
GÜNI: Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
MURAT: Okay, alles klar.
Dann zeigen wir euch, welche Zutaten wir dafür benötigen.
Richtig? Genau!
Hier haben wir 500 g Kartoffeln, 50 g Olivenöl, 1 TL Salz,
1 TL Pfeffer, 1 Knoblauchzehe, 1 EL getrockneten Oregano
und 1 EL Paprikapulver.
Was ihr auch noch je nach Geschmack benötigt…
Ich mag das einfach: Pommes mit Parmesan.
Richtig toll. [Güni stimmt zu]
60 g Parmesan. Ihr könnt je nach Geschmack auch mehr nehmen.
GÜNI: Du hast mehr genommen, oder?
MURAT: Ja. Das sind die Zutaten. Olivenöl ist ganz wichtig.
Es gibt ja gute Fette und es gibt schlechte Fette.
Du bist ein schlechter Fett, gell?
[Beide lachen]
Dann machen wir weiter. Das Erste, was wir machen, ist,
wir schneiden die Kartoffeln.
Nicht wundern, dass wir heute Handschuhe anhaben.
Ich habe mir in den Finger geschnitten.
GÜNI: [Entsetzt] Aua!
MURAT: Deswegen ziehe ich Handschuhe an, weil ich Angst habe,
dass es mir dann wehtut.
Güni hat Handschuhe an, weil ich einfach Angst habe,
dass eine Pandemie ausbricht. Deswegen…
GÜNI: Soll ich deine Mama anrufen?
MURAT: Kannst du mal meine Mutter anrufen? [Güni bejaht]
GÜNI: Gib mir mal dein Handy.
MURAT: Ich schwöre, ich rufe sie echt an.
GÜNI: Ja. Ich sage, dass du arg Schmerzen hast.
MURAT: Ich rufe sie jetzt an. Ich bin mal gespannt…
GÜNI: Ich kann kein Türkisch.
MURAT: Das ist mir sowas von egal, ob du Türkisch kannst oder nicht.
[Güni lacht]
Ich rufe jetzt meine Mutter an. Sie ist jetzt gerade in der Türkei.
Dann möchte ich mal wissen, was du sagst.
GÜNI: Murat hat arg Aua.
Was heißt „arg“? Was heißt „arg“ auf Türkisch?
MURAT: [Telefon klingelt] „Arg“ auf Türkisch?
[Doing] Ich weiß es nicht.
[Güni lacht]
Jetzt pass auf! Sei ruhig!
Wäre das jetzt geil.
Kennst du das? Erst ein großes Maul und jetzt nichts mehr, was?
GÜNI: „Anne“, gell? (Anne = Mama auf Türkisch)
MURAT: Sie geht nicht ran, ja? Doch!
VOICEOVER: Moin Güni, Zuckerschnute.
MURAT: Hallo?
VOICEOVER: Ah okay, Murat. Hast du dich verwählt?
Gerade, wo wir beim Thema sind: Ich habe letztens die Nachrichten
gesehen, die du dem Güni geschrieben hast. Sag mal, läuft da was
zwischen euch?
MURAT: Hallo?
GÜNI: Hallo anne Murat. Murat viel Aua!
MURAT: Anne?
MAMA: Efendim yavrum? (Ja, mein Kind?)
MURAT: Ne yapıyorsun anne? (Was machst du Mama?)
MAMA: Kuşluk namazı kılıyorum. (Ich bete.)
MURAT: Allah kabul etsin. (Möge es Allah akzeptieren.)
MAMA: Bugün Bayram degil. (Heute ist doch kein Bayram.)
MURAT: Biliyorum. (Ich weiß.)
Ben seni arayacağım sonra, oldu mu? (Ich rufe späte ran, ok?)
MAMA: Ne yapıyorsun sen? (Was machst du gerade?)
MURAT: Ben calışıyorum anne. (Ich arbeite, Mama.)
MAMA: Almanya’da? (In Deutschland?) [Murat stimmt zu]
GÜNI: Anne, çok Aua Murat.
MURAT: Oldu mu? (Okay?)
MAMA: Iyi yavrum. (Okay, mein Kind.)
MURAT: Ben seni yarım saat sonra ararım. (Ich rufe in 30 Min. an.)
Ben seni yarim saat sonra ararım, tamam mı?
MAMA: Tamam yavrum, hade. (Okay, mein Kind. Bis dann.)
MURAT: Okay. Danke schön Mama. Tschüss.
MAMA: Hade yavrum, hade. (Bis dann, mein Kind.)
MURAT: So, hast du gehört, was sie gesagt hat?
GÜNI: Was?
MURAT: Du sollst das Maul halten.
[Güni lacht]
Also, ganz wichtig: Die Kartoffeln als Wedges schneiden.
Sprich es mal „Wedges“ aus, ohne dass deine Dritten rausfliegen.
GÜNI: Wedges.
MURAT: Aua! [Güni lacht]
In Kartoffelspalten schneiden.
GÜNI: Spalten? [Murat stimmt zu]
Wedges? [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Geh mit dem Messer weg! Ich traue dir nicht.
GÜNI: Geh lieber weg von mir!
MURAT: Hat dir eigentlich jemand gesagt,
dass du voll intelligent aussieht?
GÜNI: Nein.
MURAT: Hat dir das schon mal jemand gesagt?
MURAT: Hätte mich auch gewundert. [Tusch]
[Güni lacht]
GÜNI: Was machst du?
MURAT: Haben dir eigentlich mal ehemalige Arbeitskollegen von dich…
Eh, von dir…
GÜNI: Von dir, von dich, mich.
MURAT: Haben sie dich schon mal angerufen und gefragt,
was du eigentlich machst? Oder dass sie dich toll finden oder so?
VOICEOVER: Also ich finde den Güni toll.
MURAT: Ich muss immer erst suchen, wo der…
GÜNI: Ich habe es nicht gern, wenn du hinter mir bist.
MURAT: Ich mag das auch nicht, wenn du hinter mir bist.
Ich traue dir nicht.
GÜNI: Hast du arg Aua?
MURAT: Ja. Das tut echt richtig weh, ohne Spaß.
GÜNI: Willst du noch mehr Aua haben? [Murat verneint]
[Güni lacht]
MURAT: So, ganz wichtig: Solange der Güni hier schneidet…
GÜNI: Kann halt dauern.
MURAT: - in Zeitlupe; das kann ein paar Stunden dauern -,
den Backofen auf 200°C Ober-/Unterhitze vorheizen.
[Musik]
Jetzt hat der Güni alles geschnitten.
Jetzt nehme ich die Wegdes, tu sie gerade hier rein.
Dann habe ich hier von Gefu den 2000 Pro GARLICO.
Das ist anscheinend die beste Presse dieser Welt. Seht ihr das?
Einfach aufladen, wie John Wayne, und auspressen.
Aua, meine Finger tun voll weh.
GÜNI: [Entsetzt] Immer noch? [Murat bejaht]
Hey, was machst du denn?
MURAT: [Doing] Ich habe etwas falsch gemacht.
Ich weiß aber nicht, was.
[Güni lacht]
Aber nicht anmerken lassen, okay? Nicht anmerken lassen.
Einfach nur winken. Lachen und winken.
GÜNI: Das brauch keiner Wissen.
Halt, lass das doch mal da drin. Du musst jetzt… Oh!
Was macht denn der? Da vorn mit dem Messer wegschneiden.
MURAT: So, fertig! Dann nehmen wir das Öl.
GÜNI: Da ist noch das ganze gute Knoblauch drin.
MURAT: Ah ja, okay. Dann nehmen wir das Öl und schütten es drüber.
Dann nehmen wir hier Thymian.
GÜNI: Oregano.
MURAT: Ah, Oregano. Entschuldigung.
Dann nehmen wir Paprika (edelsüß).
Paprika und Salz ist eigentlich alles, was die Kartoffeln brauchen.
Mehr brauchen sie nicht.
GÜNI: Wieso nimmst du kein Salz?
MURAT: Mache ich doch jetzt. Hier, Salz!
Ein bisschen Pfeffer. Ja, ich weiß.
Ich mache immer aus Versehen zu viel Pfeffer.
Der Pfeffer pfeift echt richtig rein.
[Güni lacht]
Dann nehmen wir 60 g Parmesankäse.
Da würde ich euch Parmesankäse immer empfehlen.
Ich mag am liebsten den Grana Padano. Genau.
Der ist oberhalb der Poebene in Italien.
Unterhalb der Poebene ist alles im Arsch. [Lacht]
GÜNI: Wie ist der Fettgehalt von dem?
MURAT: Ich geb‘ dir gleich Fettgehalt.
Ich sage dir gleich, welchen Fettgehalt dieses Ding hat.
Wie viel Fettgehalt hast du eigentlich?
GÜNI: Nicht viel.
MURAT: Vielleicht 85 % i. Tr.? [Güni verneint]
GÜNI: Wie ist denn dein BMI?
MURAT: Was für ein BMI?
Ich habe vielleicht einen BMW, aber keinen BMI.
[Güni lacht]
So, oh je, oh je. Du machst mich schon fertig.
Weißt du, eigentlich bin ich voll der liebe Mensch
und die Menschen denken auch, dass ich voll lieb bin.
Aber wenn du…
GÜNI: Oh halt!
MURAT: Was willst du machen?
GÜNI: Eine Umfrage unter den Mitarbeitern.
MURAT: Ich würde auch gern unter den Zuschauern eine Umfrage machen.
GÜNI: Ob du wirklich so lieb bist? [Murat stimmt zu]
Aber anonym, dass die Leute keine Angst haben um ihren Arbeitsplatz.
MURAT: Bitte hört nicht auf ihn.
Ihr könnt auch ruhig in den Kommentaren schreiben,
was ihr wirklich von Güni haltet. Ob der wirklich immer so lieb ist…
Ist er nämlich wirklich nicht. Er beleidigt mich jeden Tag.
GÜNI: Aber du bist ein ganz lieber Mensch. [Murat stimmt zu]
Josh? Schreib was.
MURAT: Du kennst ihn, Josh. Bitte.
Jeder kennt ihn. Die Querdenker kennen ihn.
GÜNI: Josh, ist er wirklich so lieb?
JOSH: Äh, ja.
[Güni lacht]
MURAT: Oh, das wird ganz schön würzig, gell? Ich sage das jetzt schon.
Güni, mir tun voll die Hände weh. Kannst du das machen? Wirklich.
GÜNI: Nein, jetzt hast du deine Hand schon verschmiert.
Ich habe noch neue. Guck mal. Ich habe neue. [Lacht]
MURAT: Das tut echt weh. Ohne Witz. Ich will jetzt nicht piensen.
GÜNI: Komm, wir rufen die Mama nochmal an.
Vielleicht kann die Mama etwas Liebes sagen.
Hast du arg Schmerzen?
MURAT: Ja, wirklich. Das tut echt richtig weh.
GÜNI: Kennst du das Lieb vom Heino? [Murat bejaht]
BEIDE: [Singend] Heidschi Bumbeidschi Bum Bum.
MURAT: Oder kennst du das Lied vom Heino, wo er sagt: „Mama…“
GÜNI: Das war „Schwarzbraun ist die Haselnuss“.
MURAT: Nein, das war Heino.
Boah! Kennst du das Lied?
GÜNI: Ja. [Singend] Schwarzbraun ist die Haselnuss.
MURAT: Dass du das kennst, wundert mich wieder nicht.
Das ist ja wirklich der Wahnsinn. Also die Wedges…
GÜNI: Welches Lied meinst du? Du wolltest doch was sagen.
MURAT: [Singend] Mamaaa…
GÜNI: Das war nicht der Heino.
MURAT: Doch, das war der Heino.
„Mama, du sollst nicht um deinen Heintje weinen!“
GÜNI: Das war der Heintje, nicht Heino!
MURAT: Auf jeden Fall geht’s weiter.
Ich kann mit dir nicht diskutieren.
Da werde ich einfach nur aggressiv.
[Güni lacht]
Nehmt die Kartoffel-Wedges. Ganz wichtig: Die Scheibenseite…
GÜNI: Die Schalenseite!
MURAT: Die Schalenseite. Entschuldigung. Tut mir voll leid.
[Güni lacht]
Die Schalenseite auf das Backblech, weil da wird es richtig kross.
Jetzt ordnen wir das so an.
[Musik]
Jetzt ist das Backblech fertig.
Güni, kannst du das Backblech in den Ofen schieben?
Auf 200°C, ungefähr 35-45 Min.
Das kommt immer auf den Backofen drauf an. Ganz wichtig!
GÜNI: Ja? So lange?
MURAT: Ja, wirklich.
Da merkt man, dass du in deinem Leben noch nicht so oft gekocht hast.
GÜNI: Ja, ja. Ich bin froh, dass ich das jetzt von dir lernen kann.
[Musik]
MURAT: Während die Kartoffeln, wie gesagt,
35-45 Min. im Backofen sind,
machen wir schon mal unsere Crispy Chickens. Okay? So!
Was wir dafür brauchen, sind natürlich Chips.
Da nehmt ihr ungefähr eine 300 g-Packung.
Können auch ein bisschen weniger sein.
Ich habe jetzt gerade 40 g extra gekriegt. Wahnsinn!
Dann haben wir hier 500 g Hähnchenbrust. Ganz wichtig.
GÜNI: Filet.
MURAT: Filet, genau! Danke, Güni.
Dann haben wir 1 EL Milch, 2 Eier, 1 EL Paprika (edelsüß),
1 TL Chiliflocken, 1 TL Salz und Pfeffer und 4 EL Mehl.
Das Mehl brauchen wir für die Panade; das ist ganz wichtig.
Jetzt fangen wir an.
Bei den Chips, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen,
ist das keine Produktplatzierung. Wir werden nicht dafür bezahlt.
Ich habe auch für die Chips bezahlt. Die haben wir selbst gekauft.
Das sind echt meine Lieblingschips. [Güni stimmt zu]
Ehrlich? [Güni bejaht]
Ich glaube auch, das sind die meistgekauften Chips Deutschlands.
Und dann gibt’s so eine andere…
GÜNI: Wir sind uns doch so ähnlich, gell?
MURAT: [Rewind] Überhaupt nicht. Gott sei Dank nicht!
Mein Gott! Boah!
Gott sei Dank kannst du nicht hören, was ich denke.
GÜNI: Die Größe ist ein kleines Problem,
aber das kriegen wir auch noch in den Griff, gell? [Murat bejaht]
Kleiner. [Murat lacht]
MURAT: Dann fangen wir an, die Dinger zu schneiden, Güni.
Hier ist es echt cool. Also ich mag Hähnchenfilet am liebsten.
GÜNI: So 1 cm? [Murat bejaht]
MURAT: Ja, Güni. Das ist doch kein Gulasch. Schon ein bisschen größer.
Was ist denn das?
GÜNI: So 1 cm-Streifen? [Murat bejaht]
Du sollst sowieso langsam essen.
MURAT: Dann quirle ich das Ei.
Jetzt nehmen wir das Fleisch, was der Güni schon geschnitten hat.
Güni, ist aber riesengroß. Was ist denn das?
Was ist denn das?
GÜNI: Die werden halt so groß. So?
MURAT: Die werden halt so groß. Die wachsen, oder wie?
GÜNI: Ja, das sind meine. Die kleinen sind deine.
MURAT: Ja, okay. Tun wir das Fleisch hier rein. Perfekt!
Jetzt nehmen wir die Milch und geben sie in ein extra Teller.
Jetzt die Eier,
Paprika edelsüß,
Chiliflocken,
ein bisschen Salz,
ein bisschen Pfeffer.
Dann verrühren wir das schon mal. Jetzt haben wir das verrührt.
Jetzt haben wir verschiedene Panaden.
Jetzt machen wir Folgendes:
Normalerweise, ich habe das schon öfters gesehen, tun die Leute…
Machen wir eins nach dem anderen.
Jetzt nehmen wir hier die Hähnchenteile und geben es hier rein.
GÜNI: [Doing] Nein, erst ins Mehl.
MURAT: Erst ins Mehl? Okay. [Güni lacht]
Jetzt nehmen wir hier die Hähnchenteile und wenden es erst im Mehl.
Ich finde es immer ganz cool, dass wir kleine Teller haben.
Danach kommen sie in die Panade.
GÜNI: Machen wir da Chips rein?
Dann kann man die gleich ein bisschen kleiner machen.
MURAT: Genau. Jetzt ist es so:
Normalerweise machen es jetzt viele so. Die machen erstmal…
Hau drauf, Güni.
GÜNI: Ich denke, du willst sie hier reingeben?
MURAT: Nein, nein, Güni. Darf ich?
GÜNI: Dann sind sie alle zerbröselt. Kannst du doch aufheben.
MURAT: Ja, aber die kannst du immer wieder in die Panade geben.
[Chipstüte]
GÜNI: Das aber zuhalten, wo die Luft rausgeht.
MURAT: Oh, so viel ist es gar nicht.
Geben wir es doch gleich hier rein.
GÜNI: Hmm?
MURAT: Siehst du? Machen wir es gleich rein. Das ist nicht so viel.
Krass, wenn man es mal kleingemacht hat…
Wieviel eigentlich Luft ist, gell?
Das hat man so gar nicht auf dem Schirm.
Guck mal, wie wenig das ist.
Das ist eine Mogelpackung. Da ist nur Luft drin.
GÜNI: Aus dir haben sie auch schon Luft rausgelassen.
MURAT: Ja, ja. Da oben ist auch eine Mogelpackung.
So einen Riesenschädel, aber nur Luft drin. [Güni lacht]
Warte mal ganz kurz. So.
Also Güni, hast du das Ding gemacht?
GÜNI: Ja, warte. Ich mache das so runter, tun wir ins Mehl.
MURAT: Wir müssen so eine Panierstraße machen, Güni.
[Güni stimmt zu]
Guck mal hier.
[Musik]
Dann nehme ich sie heraus, nicht alle auf einmal.
Zack, da rein, zwei…
[Musik]
Ganz wichtig: Wenn ihr sie aus der Tüte herausholt,
dann drückt die Panade nochmal schön an das Fleisch ran.
Güni, kannst du so lange noch panieren?
Und immer lachen, während du das machst.
Grinsen, ja, immer schön. Das ist immer wichtig,
weil du guckst immer so ernst.
[Doing] Dann merken die, wie blöd du bist.
[Güni lacht]
GÜNI: Kennst du die Raupe Nimmersatt? [Murat bejaht]
MURAT: Kann das sein?
Wie nennt sich das immer, wenn man immer das Gleiche sagt?
Du fragst mich immer, ob ich eine Raupe Nimmersatt bin.
Woran liegt das denn?
Sag mal, bei dir lief doch etwas schief in der Kindheit.
Kann das sein? Doch, doch. Bei dir lief etwas schief in der Kindheit.
Du bist doch bestimmt gegen die Schleuse geschwommen als Kind, oder?
GÜNI: Nein, im hohen Alter bin ich mit den falschen Leuten umgegangen.
MURAT: Mit wem?
Stell dir mal vor, ich hätte…
Weißt du, was ich manchmal überlege?
Wenn ich dich früher kennengelernt hätte oder wenn wir uns früher…
GÜNI: Ich glaube, dann wärst du gar nicht so alt geworden.
[Beide lachen]
MURAT: So, tun wir rein, Güni.
[Musik]
Die Chips, die ihr drin habt, könnt ihr natürlich nicht mehr essen.
Ganz, ganz wichtig! Esst sie bitte nicht mehr!
Die geben wir einfach hier rein, so.
Jetzt machen wir daraus noch…
GÜNI: Chips-Flocken.
MURAT: Ja, Chips-Flocken, coole Cracker.
[Musik]
Dass wir nachher nichts mehr wegschmeißen müssen – ganz wichtig:
Bitte kein Food Waste! Nichts wegschmeißen. Waste heißt Müll, Güni.
Das ist das, was du redest.
[Beide lachen]
Machst du noch ein bisschen Parmesan rein?
[Musik]
So, perfekt! Jawoll!
GÜNI: [Summt] Mama… [Summt]
MURAT: Ehrlich? Ich würde nie darauf kommen,
dass er kurz vor der Rente steht. Weißt du, was ich meine?
Ich bin auch froh,
dass ich bei dir nicht in der Kindergartengruppe war, weißt du das?
Kannst du das kurz machen, Güni?
Mir tun echt die Hände weh, wenn ich es mache.
Ich werfe mich unter Schmerzen ins Feuer. Weißt du, was ich meine?
GÜNI: Aah, pass auf, gell? [Murat bejaht]
MURAT: Guck mal! So ein paar Kügelchen formen und dazwischen legen.
[Musik]
Diese Bällchen…
GÜNI: Nicht Bällchen. Mache sie doch lieber so.
Wenn du sie zu rund machst, brauchen sie zu lange.
Dann werden sie innen nicht fertig. [Murat stimmt zu]
MURAT: Und dann geben wir sie nachher den Veganern als Protein Balls.
Weißt du, was das ist? [Güni bejaht]
GÜNI: Mach noch ein bisschen Gras drauf. [Murat stimmt zu]
Der soll mir bitte nicht so nah kommen.
MURAT: Guck mal hier! Das sieht aus, guck mal, wie die Chippendales.
GÜNI: Guck mal, deine Oberarme. Guck mal, guck mal, guck mal!
MURAT: Zeigst du mal ganz kurz?
Warte, jetzt! Ist auch der Arm drauf?
GÜNI: Das sieht aus wie der Hinterlauf vom Schwein.
MURAT: Wahnsinn, ey! Ich muss mich voll anstrengen.
Guck, meine Oberarme.
Ich glaube, das hätte mal ein Oberschenkel werden sollen.
Jetzt haben wir ja die Kartoffeln schon seit ca. 20 Min. drin.
Jetzt gebe ich es unten rein.
Jetzt sparen wir gleichzeitig Energie.
So, und das tun wir gleich hier rein.
Danke schön, Güni. Du bist so ein lieber Mensch.
GÜNI: Ja, ich weiß.
MURAT: Und so hilfsbereit. [Güni stimmt zu]
Alles rein und nochmal 20 Min. drin lassen.
Dann haben wir die Kartoffeln ca. 40 Min. drin gelassen
und die Filetteilchen 20 Min.
[Güni pfeift]
Hast du dich gerade am Backblech verbrannt?
GÜNI: Ja. Wieso hast du nicht gesagt, dass sie heiß ist?
MURAT: Es ist heiß. Entschuldigung.
[Güni lacht]
[Uhr]
Jetzt sind die Hähnchenteile und Kartoffeln fertig
und holen sie heraus.
So, Güni. Jetzt kannst du sie schon mal schön anrichten.
Hier hast du eine Zange.
GÜNI: Wo soll ich sie hintun?
MURAT: In meine Hosentasche. [Güni lacht]
Mein Gott! Warum habe ich die Bretter hingestellt?
Ah, hör auf!
GÜNI: Ja, zeig deine Hosentasche.
Auf welches Brett soll ich es anrichten?
MURAT: Ach so. Ich würde hier die Hähnchenteile
und hier die Kartoffeln ablegen.
GÜNI: Wenn ich mich verbrenne, weißt du ja…
MURAT: Wir hätten vielleicht mehr Kartoffeln zubereiten müssen.
Ohne Witz. Also das ist jetzt ca. für 4 Personen oder 1,5 Günis.
750 g Kartoffeln wären vielleicht besser gewesen, gell?
Aber die Hähnchenteile reichen ruhig für 4 Personen.
GÜNI: Dann isst du die Kartoffeln und ich das Fleisch.
[Musik]
MURAT: Eigentlich ganz easy gemacht, auch richtig schnell.
Wenn der Güni nicht dabei gewesen wäre,
wäre ich vielleicht 15 Min. schneller gewesen,
aber sieht richtig cool aus, gell?
Sieht aus wie bei Kentucky…
GÜNI: Fried
BEIDE: Chicken.
MURAT: Genau. Richtig cool. Es riecht auch wahnsinnig.
Das ist für mich ein richtig cooles Fingerfood,
wenn man abends mal Fußballschaut oder…
GÜNI: Du hast doch Aua am Finger.
MURAT: Frauen-Wrestling.
[Beide lachen]
Jetzt haben wir natürlich eine Person, die unparteiisch ist
und sie holen wir jetzt, und zwar meine liebe Tochter Samira.
Die Samira muss probieren.
GÜNI: Unser Schatz.
MURAT: Ich muss aber ehrlich sagen,
diese Idee kommt auch von der Samira,
weil die Samira guckt sich immer diese TikTok-Videos an
und sagte nur: „Papa, kannst du das mal nachmachen?“
Okay? Du bist auch ehrlich, gell? [Samir bejaht]
Wenn du zu ehrlich bist, Hausarrest. Du weißt Bescheid!
[Güni lacht]
Cool, oder? [Samira stimmt zu]
Bist du stolz auf mich? [Samira bejaht]
Auf Güni auch?
SAMIRA: Ja.
MURAT: Was würdest du daran ändern? Würdest du es ein bisschen
schärfer machen, mehr Salz oder irgendetwas oder ist es genau richtig?
SAMIRA: Ich würde ein bisschen mehr Salz reintun.
MURAT: Genau, das habe ich auch gemerkt.
Ich habe echt gedacht, dass die Chips richtig würzig sind,
aber man kann wirklich noch ein Muggeseggele Salz dazu geben.
Weißt du, was Muggeseggele ist? [Samira verneint]
Egal, Schwäbisch.
SAMIRA: Ich würde noch ein bisschen weniger Chili reinmachen.
MURAT: Ja. Warte, du kannst nicht alles auf einmal essen.
Wir müssen noch Fotos schießen. Probiere mal noch die Kartoffeln.
[Güni lacht]
Auch cool?
SAMIRA: Schön knusprig.
MURAT: Schön knusprig, gell? Richtig cool gemacht. Hammer!
Mmh! Richtig lecker. Dann kannst du noch unsere Chips Balls probieren.
Die sind nicht so, oder? Auch gut?
SAMIRA: Doch!
MURAT: Ja? [Samira bejaht]
Okay. Bei sowas müsst ihr aufpassen. Es ist wirklich nicht gesund.
Also alles andere als gesund,
weil in den Chips ist schon genug Fett drin,
dann noch die ganzen Marinaden und alles.
Also es ist wirklich nicht gesund, schmeckt aber super.
[Samira stimmt zu]
Kann es sein, dass du dich schon oftmals im Leben nicht gesund ernährt
hast, weil du siehst aus, als…
GÜNI: Ja, aber ich hätte gern so einen athletischen Körper wie du.
Aber das ist mir nicht gegeben.
MURAT: Ach so. Ich schau mir das mal an.
Hammer! Mmh! Echt lecker.
Und was machst du dich größer?
[Güni lacht]
War gut?
Alles klar, bis dann. Tschüss! Macht’s gut!
Hatet die anderen. Hatet nicht uns und abonniert den Kanal,
auch wenn er nicht uns gehört.
Und kommentiert, genau! Schreibt dem Güni etwas Nettes.
Du haust ja auch rein, gell?
Tschüss!
GÜNI: Es müssen noch Fotos gemacht werden!
MURAT: Warte mal kurz. Eins noch.
Mmh! Hammer! Ehrlich, echt super!
GÜNI: Kann man ja noch ein bisschen nachsalzen. [Murat stimmt zu]
Du sollst aufhören.
MURAT: Ja, ich höre auf. Tschüss!
[Musik]